Strawberries have a lot of DNA, because they're
an example of a really cool phenomenon called polyploidy.
Ploidy is how many copies of every chromosome you
have. So, polyploidy is when you end up with
a lot more copies than normal. For example, humans
have two copies of every chromosome. They get one
from mom and one from dad. So we're considered
to be diploid. Di, meaning two. But strawberries have
eight copies of every chromosome, which makes
them octoploid. Octo, meaning eight. They get
four copies of every chromosome from each parent. So, if we wanted to use
a sample for our extraction that has a lot of DNA, which of the following would
we want to use? An organism that's triploid, tetraploid, hexaploid or octoploid?